hi - climbing I'm currently an undergrad
the Oxford studying physics is in the
college the reason I'm making this video
is because a couple of weeks ago I post
a comment on site business schools
channel on one their videos saying I
could give the device if they wanted a
hand in applying to science for physics
specifically and I actually got quite a
few people contacting me so I thought
this would be a good way to get just
some general observations and some
advice out into people's easily
accessible information stream so a
couple of common questions that kept
coming up I just thought I'd try an
answer here and if this gets a good
response then I will put some more
videos and incidentally if there's
anything this video that I don't cover
please by all means leave a comment or
send me a message and I will try and
make enough everything and try and get
back to you if not personally then in
another video like this one and the
first common question that kept coming
up was what do you box bridge I just
start saying Oxford in particular is
another place in Cambridge here what the
what Oxbridge look for in students and
there are two real things they look for
the first thing is kind of obvious where
that you have to have really high grades
and you're looking at basically straight
A's the very least a level I don't know
what you come to leave IB I've got to be
the best person to know about that and
at least one maybe to a stars predict
afraid to and that's really the people
who I'm at the university with
everyone's got straight A's and I can't
really think of any one of tough my hair
if you hadn't I was the last year they
didn't have no stars point out so I
would know but I'd say 90% of people
have one or two a stars you know
probably more so that's the first step
secondly they look for people who really
are into their subject they live well
they don't necessarily live and breathe
and excrete it but they do really enjoy
doing and that much does that the key
thing you genuinely don't find it a task
to do it and there's a reason for that
and it's anything apparently since
getting in but the reason
isn't because it makes you a better
person does make you a better student
but it means you're actually going to
survive the course at the end of it
because unless you really don't want
staying up till 2 o'clock in the morning
god no telling nights a week really
putting hours working 60 hour weeks
unless you're willing to put in that
level of s even if it's not required all
the time you're not going to survive the
course so it's not to exclude people
it's literally just say well are you
going to survive that's why it's
important for two things if they look
for academic results dedication and
actual enjoyment of your subject the
next common question that kept coming up
was how far do universities look back
your academic record basically other
g''l vacuoles GCSE you just saps
whatever known as asked that is to me in
particular case stand up to my AAS
results my module results they look to
my 80 predictive of course what your
results are going to be bet your
offering based on and they didn't really
look emerging cities at all and I don't
know if that's specifically a science
thing or 50 marketing but as far as I
can tell the results that really matter
at the most recent ones the only reason
they would pick you up on your GCSE
results or your SATs result is if
they're unusually bad for somebody's
applying so GCSE for instance if you
don't get any stars and if you're
applying talks but you've got really
good results in your guesses they'll
probably ask you why you think that's
the case and in some ways that's kind of
good fear interview because it means
that you have lines talked about you say
well I got much more discipline I really
wouldn't worry about GCSE results if you
think they're going to hold you back
because they really don't matter when it
comes to applying
don't think that because you didn't get
11 a stars or whatever then you're not
smart enough because it's just not the
case you know the friend of money doing
that skit Cambridge is on track for a
first who've got a B at GCSE you know we
didn't get straight I stars at all so
it's nothing to worry about and it's
just your SS account so make sure you
only OAS is and you have good a to
predictive something else that
came out quite frequently was how do I
see the college and if their advantage
in choosing a bigger college because
they're going to let more people in and
this is again something that I've only
sort of included into since talking to
people having got in but the idea of the
Oxford system anyway it's similar in
Cambridge with the pooling system but
the idea being you have your interviews
and your assessed with your good enough
to do the course you're not assessed
whether you're good enough to do it at
that College say there are four places
available at the college you apply to
and if you want the best for applicants
that they interview there you will be
given a place of that college because
that's where you said you like to be but
if you're not one of the top four
applicants but they think you're
suitable for the course and you do well
and if you're good enough for it then
they will give you a place at another
college they will find you a place
everyone who leaves their college thinks
that it's the best college so there's no
advantage at all in applying to a bigger
college because you think there's more
places or a smaller College because
you're more likely to get in because
it's less applicants it honestly just
apply based on the things like sporting
criteria if you're a keen sportsman
sports woman
if you musician is a really good music
scene or if it's just close in proximity
to your faculty or whatever we don't
want to be a million miles away from
your department
equally it only just across the street
that is that means you're never gonna
see Oxford or Cambridge the next
question that came up quite frequently
was people asking what they should
include in their personal statement and
it's all based really on walks the walk
in which are looking for so the big
thing that I would say is show that
you're into your subject talk about your
work experience if you're doing medicine
in particular like the time you spent
either working at a school or an old
folks home or anything like that just
show that you've had dedication of the
past your subject and say what you go
out of it
don't just say like oh I love to do such
and such and such and such
say that you enjoy doing it beyond that
it's all about your interests they're
looking for rounded people pay more
people to
we need to like mr. vehicle play sport
or you know they want people who aren't
just work ultimatums water motor they
want people who are people my caste is
walking away in like a couple sentences
say you know I play saxophone and I like
the music of Bach so yeah that's the
best advice I can give just to make sure
that you come across and how interested
in your subject you are and don't
understand yourself it's not one of
those times where you can just you're
afraid of being arrogant yes I know
you're there it's really a time when you
have to try and save yourself to the
university system one chance you're
going to get to give it like that the
last thing that people ask about the
interviews and just you know help and
people asking about how to deal with you
to be situation best of a signing gift
for that was what a medic in the year
above me told me and that's just to
relax pretend you're not in your
interview think of it as talking to a
teacher whatever because in my first
three interviews I was under pressure I
didn't really perform very well
especially my maths interview I you know
I was shaking I was really nervous I
wasn't falling well at all
and as a result did as well as I could
have done my last interview and
registered Peters much more relaxed I
thought well I probably haven't got it
already so let's just try to have a bit
of fun as a result I wasn't in a
high-stress environment I was relaxed I
really don't get stressed because if you
get stressed you went performs alone I
know it's a really hard thing to take in
and to actually do it honestly you'll
teach the world of good
stop worrying go on that kick out and I
like there is a lot more thing I like to
say the castle of your expectations of
university experience
I came to Oxford thinking it's going to
be amazing I I'm feel like love it make
loads of new friends and yeah I've made
lots of new friends I have enjoyed it
but it isn't the best
spice bread I think it'd be safe to say
the first eight weeks the first my first
term Nikolas most miserable eight weeks
in my life
so be careful about going into thinking
it's clearly fantastic I'm not saying
it's going to awful for most people they
found it you know to little expectations
just don't go in expecting to be blown
away so even though you probably will be
you can be really disappointed so good
luck Turner's apply I really wish you
well and you know contact me if there's
anything in this video that you think I
should talk about or if there's any
questions if you want to pose to me
either comment on the video send me a
message and I will get back to you
either in video form
or I will send you your face by face
connect I will send you a YouTube
message or comment on your channel so
yeah be great to hear from you guys and
I hope your do a long I hope to see you
Laxus and not Cambridge